في هذه الحياه يعني بنصادف كثير من
الاشخاص الفضوليين اللي يحبوا يعرفوا كل
شيء لكن الفضول اللي راح اتكلم عنه في هذا
الخبر يعني غريب منه شويه
يعني لانه وصل عند رجل برازيلي اسمه
بانتظار لمصر اللي لدرجه عاليه اوصل عنده
هذا الفضول رجع عاليه كثير في الرجل قرر
انه يعرف ايش رح يصير لما يموت ومين راح
يحضر جنازته تحدي يعني عامل له ازمه الرجل
عمره 60 سنه بيعمل في تنظيم الجنازه
وبيشرف على المئات من المناسبات لاحياء
ذكرى حياه الاخرين ومن بعد التخطيط خمسه
اشهر نفذ خطه اللي حابب يعرف من خلالها
مين راح يحضر جناسته ففي كده الاول قام
نشر بوست على فيسبوك طلب من الناس تصلي له
وتدعي له وين ما كان وكان متقص في الصوره
انه يبين المستشفى خلفه والثاني يوم نشر
بوست اعلن فيه عن وفاته اعلان صدم عائلته
واصدقائه واللي صاروا بيتسالوا عن سبب
تفاصيل الوفاه وايش اللي صار مع
من بعدها تم نشر تفاصيل الوداع ومكان
الجنازه وبالفعل جو اصدقائه وعائلته كمان
لمكان الجنازه والقداس في كنيسه الصغيره
بمسقط راسه وبس بدات مراسم الجنازه طلع
صوت وعبر مكبرات الصوت في الكنيسه وكده
كان المشهد
[موسيقى]
يعني مثل ما شفته بعد ما تجمعوا المعزين
من اصدقائه وعائلته في الكنيسه بدات
المراسم بصوت وعبر مكبرات الصوت اللي
موجوده في الكنيسه واصحابه وفكروا انه
مسجل هذه الرساله قبل ما يتوفى وكان بيعرض
صوره مع اصحابه خلال الاعوام اللي عاشها
والناس بتبكي وقاتلين نفسهم من الزعل
وفجاه طلع قدامهم كده وكمل كلامه ولا لا
وجلس 12 دقيقه كامله يحاضر فيهم وانه اللي
عمل كده وانه كان حابب يعرف مين راح يحضر
جنازته بعد ما يتوفى طبعا الذهول كان
عنوان الموقف اللي صار وتحولت مشاعر الحزن
للغضب والانتقاد بسبب اللي عملوه وحقيقه
يعني انا ماني من الناس اللي يعني يؤيده
العنف بس هذا اعتقد الشخص لو كانوا ضربوه
كان حلال في الضبط بصراحه يعني
[موسيقى]